what else are you working on right now
what's going on oh my god so many things
I'm working with a bunch of different
Studios on some digital projects and
some TV projects I got my book still
going on I'm getting into music soon
gonna be singing yeah what kind of music
it's like rock country pop okay the
first single come in probably winter see
the name for it no but you're recording
right now yes I'm so excited about it no
I know it's actually the first time I'm
really talking about it okay yeah here
at Wango Tango it's why I'm here I'm
getting getting into the soul of singing
yeah so you could be here on this stage
next year I really hope that that
happens yeah you I feel like you could
be a pop star I'm I'm already a pop star
just add the music and there you go
they're writing your own music are you
working with producer writing my own
music oh like you mean like the sound
yeah yeah basically yeah Karenina limpio
is revealing her musical aspirations to
ET at Wango Tango over the weekend The
Bachelor alum is also ready to take the
next step with boyfriend John Junger I
have had a boyfriend for over a year and
how's it going do we were ring yet yet
not yet anyways talking about that yes
have been for a while it's coming very
soon okay look she's like any day now
have you picked out the ring no no no he
knows what I like I don't want a diamond
oh you don't what do you want I want
something totally different yeah I've
been engaged before I've had a diamond I
feel like all the people on The Bachelor
got a diamond like I don't want a dime
and it's so like oh the diamond the
diamond I just I want something
different and here's what she had to say
about hanabi's season of The
Bachelorette are you watching this
season I know you weren't the biggest
fan of Hannah but have you been watching
are you liking how it's going yes
I'm gonna watch I mean like if I'm like
home and in front of the TV like a watch
yes yeah have you changed your mind
about Hannah I mean I don't really like
mind her I know I don't know I mean I I
don't really mind her I don't know I'm
so like well I got with all the
bachelors stuff either I watch it when I
can or like if I can I can you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]